former Irish mobster Edward Mackenzie's
new memoir is called Street Soldier
during this hour and ten minute of n
he's joined by co-authors Phyllis Karras
and Ross Moscato portions of this
program contain language that some may
find offensive
welcome to Borders Books and Music in
Peabody Massachusetts I'm pleased to see
so many people here tonight that are
excited by books and we're welcoming
Edward J McKenzie jr. Phyllis Karras and
Ross Moscato the authors of street
soldier my life as an enforcer for
whitey bulger and the Boston Irish mob
John Dean in the New York Times Book
Review said Eddie Mackenzie's graphic
account of his life as a violent street
criminal in South Boston is also almost
unspeakably brutal cold-blooded ruthless
merciless callous cruel and fascinating
reading it is like happening upon a
street crime and entering the
perpetrators mind let's first hear from
Ross Moscato on his experience well
first off I'd like to thank Borders
Books and Music for having us he had
tonight and as well I would like to
thank c-span for filming this and
broadcasting this and this is a very
exciting opportunity for all of us the
book we've been fortunate the book has
been very very well received from coast
to coast and I guess specifically
tonight we have a I guess an assembly of
bibliophiles and that you come out to a
bookstore and those who are viewing on
c-span are very interested in the
production of books the whole experience
of the writing of a book and this has
been a very very extraordinary
opportunity one thing that's very
important to understand and that we've
described this before is that all books
are something of a conspiracy and I mean
that in a very benign fashion not in the
conspiracy we we described in Eddie's
book in that books involve editors books
involve writers books involve researches
books involve enthusiasm that is
generated from a lot of different areas
and we're very fortunate for instance
David Ratner is here tonight from Newman
Communications which is the group that
has done some exemplary
and very exceptional work in helping
publicize the book
and I think he can probably empathize
with me and that even in a public
relations and the communications from
just to get a letter out involves
everyone's fingerprints on a page so you
can imagine your imagine if you magnify
that and you multiply that on the book
and what happens and what I what I what
we did do here was Street soldier is
Eddie we're very fortunate he's a good
writer and he is I like to tell the
story one time that a professor from
Northeastern saw something that Eddie
had written that had not been touched
and not had been edited by anyone and he
was joking but only half joking and he
said well why do you even need anyone to
work with because he really liked
Eddie's work and we are very fortunate
both Phyllis and I and in terms of the
development of a book I was also
fortunate in that not only that I worked
with Eddie who had a great story but I
worked with an accomplished author and
Phyllis Karras who has written six books
prior to this my correct six books prior
to this so my own apprenticeship and
storytelling was I was very fortunate in
this and what we did with this book you
see three names and John Dean in the New
York Times said that the book was
written by committee but of course all
books are written by committee I think
we just probably a little more explicit
in describing this for the reader and
the public in terms of how this went and
it's a very good story it's a true story
it's a very very stock upsetting
sometimes entertaining humorous violent
story and I guess that's precisely the
reason that it has done so well and
again I thank you very much for coming
and I thank c-span
I thank Borders Books in music and now I
will hand it over to Phyllis Karras who
whom I very fortunate to have worked
with and she will provide you some
further insight and background as to
Street soldier thank you
hi thanks Ross I'm Phyllis Karras and my
friend here is Eddie McKenzie together
his Ross told you all we wrote a book
street soldier
my life is an enforcer for Whitey Bulger
and the Boston Irish mob it's the story
of Eddie's life not mine not Ross's for
the two of us were just the conduits for
Eddie's thoughts and his memories
however I did want to take just a minute
to tell you how a relatively mild me and
bu professor in Northshore lady got to
spend three years of her life here in
the innermost secrets of a Whitey Bulger
leg-breaker
a man with a nine-page double sided
criminal record with over 50 entries we
did not run into each other at the
Peabody mall and the aboard is nor in my
hometown of Marblehead are his hometown
of Southie our connection was made in
the north end office of my agent Helen
Reese for reason I will never be able to
understand Helen thought I was the right
writer along with Ross for Eddie's story
so through emails meetings that be you
and phone calls the book was written
sold canceled rewritten resold and
finally at long last on May first
published it has been a wonderful ride
since that May first publication with
positive reviews in the New York Times
The Washington Post
Kirkus Library Journal Publishers Weekly
Boston Herald four weeks on the Boston
Globe's bestseller list dozens of
national radio spots for Eddie as well
as his appearances on national
television with Pat Buchanan Wolf
Blitzer before that on 60 minutes
however I do want to further explain
that neither Ross nor I nor our
publisher would have been interested in
working with Eddie and having him
helping him tell his story if not our
belief that the book he had in him had
redeeming qualities there was no doubt
what Eddie did was appalling but all
that ended 13 years ago and even if he
isn't a redeemed man himself as he will
be the first to admit the window that he
offered
on to a very dark corner of our society
is important in revealing
unlike other true crime books street
soldier neither glamorizes the gangster
life
no romanticizes eddie it makes it clear
that those involved in such behavior are
bad dangerous men that they will destroy
other human beings without giving it a
second thought that such a way of life
is a dead end and that the likes of
these people will always be with us
there is value in honestly depicting
these realities even if we prefer to
pretend they don't exist in Eddie who
was earned a college degree and is
raising two daughters as a single parent
should be recognized for having the
intellect and ability to portray the
world he knew in a way that makes for
compelling reading and though perhaps we
do not have to forgive or excuse his
past sins he should be credited with
accepting the fact of who he was and
being willing to share his experience
honestly and to move forward with his
life in a positive way it's been a long
journey for the book for my relationship
with Eddie and Russ but nowhere as long
as the journey that brought Eddie from
the dock and ugly crevices at Foster Kea
foster care at it's very worst to the
even darker and uglier crevices of
whitey Bulger's world Ross and I know
the story very well but we want you to
hear some of it firsthand so let me hand
the podium over to my co-author my leg
breaker my friend Eddie Mack
boy where do I begin um I know I guess
I'll open up by saying you know every
time I do one of these uh people say
you're a veteran ed because you've been
you've probably done about thirty of
these but everyone's like a new
adventure to me to try to express myself
and try to say what's in the book and
try to bring you folks into the psyche
in the world of what I called the street
predator and what I called my
neighborhood as the jungle and to do
that I'm going to have to be a little
gritty with you folks tonight I might
even swear a little bit but I'll do my
best to be to be good but I can't be
fake about this I have to just say it
like it is I'm going to open up with the
extra bits and pieces that I pulled from
the book and kind of turned into a
little speech but before I do this I
just want to say yes I did put it all
behind me most of it behind me I slipped
a little bit along the way but I'm
fixing that too but most importantly I
got my GED and I walked into the
University of Massachusetts at Boston
and said Here I am I need to get a
degree I need to do something with my
life for the sake of my children so that
I can prove to them and I can prove to
everybody else that there are people
like me out there and there are people
and once they decide to change and make
something themselves they can do it
needless to say I'm not on no eagle trip
or anything like that
I got my degree in three years and it's
a pretty large degree of all things I
figured since I was studying the other
side of the fence I might want to study
the legal side I knew the terminology
very well so I aced quite a few classes
and one of the very first classes I
studied was cultural diversity through
literature and in this class I had to
write about Malcolm X I had to read the
book and I had to write about this guy
and I make some references to Malcolm X
in my book street soldier and it's kind
of you know ironic because here you have
probably one of the most fiercest form
of racists in South Boston along with
Frankie MacDonald all the kids stolen
the busses stolen the blacks and for you
know forced busing right at the
forefront of everything and Here I am at
the University of Massachusetts studying
about Malcolm X and I'll start with that
this is what I call the street predator
and it's in street soldier how do I
explain to you who and what I am most
people are so removed from the life of
an urban street predator that they can't
even begin to find a point of reference
for never mind an understanding of what
we are about Malcolm X said it perfectly
in his autobiography the hustler out
there in the ghetto jungles has less
respect for the white power structure
than any other Negro in North America he
wrote the ghetto hustler is internally
restrained by nothing
he has no religion no concept of
morality no civic responsibility no fear
nothing to survive he is constantly out
there preying on others probing for any
human weakness like a ferret the ghetto
hustler is forever frustrated restless
and anxious for some action whatever he
undertakes he commits himself to it
fully absolutely of course he was
talking specifically about the young
urban black predator but he could have
just as well been talking about a young
Eddie McKenzie or Ronnie watts or
Frankie MacDonald all white and as
Pradesh assess they come Malcolm X knew
what motivates a young thug on the
street black or white who was not
educated who has been deprived loved who
has been beaten and neglected and who
was looked at by society not only in a
patronizing disparaging and indifferent
manner but also with fear yeah that's
right fear it's the type of look that
energizes and fuels the rage in you and
when that happens you say you say to
yourself now I'm going to give you
something to be afraid of Malcolm X
understood how the street predator is an
animal devoid of conscience whose
primary reason for being is to survive
and win it all cost and let me tell you
when you are robbing and mugging you are
not thinking oh [ __ ]
I can't believe what a dirtball I am one
of these days I'm going to see the light
and be overcome with regret for the sad
mistakes I made never happened folks
what you are doing is trying to win in a
brutal environment in which you have
established your own rules rules that
tilt the playing field in your favor you
steal and intimidate and brutalize like
you're in the jungle you don't have the
confidence to think and play by the
rules of a civilized in-law
a biting society so you ignore that game
and play the game of the underworld the
game that you have made up there wasn't
much we wouldn't do
oh sure most of the guys I hung with but
not all recognize some code of honor yet
anyhow even those where's kids and
senior citizens in the handicap lived
was fair game
I for example wouldn't rip off or mess
directly with a senior citizen or a
little kid or anyone who was handicapped
but let me tell you and I could say this
because I never fell victim to drugs or
booze at least for any long stretch when
chemicals grab hold of his mind the
urban predator was not only an animal
but a crazed and stupid animal
the tripping and drugged out predator is
the most dangerous predator addicts will
beat their own mother to score money to
pay for a fix
violence was my drug when I gave someone
a beating it was better than the high
any drug he pulled from a speedball the
more I did actual damage or at least put
up the front of danger the big of my
rave on the streets even animals in the
woods understand the concept of
intimidation watch a cat arch its back
and hiss or a dog bear its teeth and
ground I know where these animals are
coming from my back was arched and my
teeth bared as I combed the streets in
search of my own prey in the world of
the streets at least in my case there
was also a desire to establish a
position of leadership
even if leading meant being the king
predator it turned me on the beat of
baddest and meanest sob on the streets
the guy no one messed with and to obtain
that position I was as vicious as they
come let me tell you something else
except for the rarest of exceptions and
I like to believe I represent one of
those exceptions the street predator
never sees the light
he never appreciates that his way is
erroneous and damning and even when he
gets caught he's certain it's society
screwing him for playing the game the
way it should be played now I'm going to
read just a couple quick excerpts from
this and you folks can ask questions and
believe me when I tell you don't be shy
ask me anything you want but when you
ask me be ready for a straightforward
answer I'm not going to beat around the
bush with anybody
yt was an institution unto himself
brilliant ruthless murderous Lucifer
personified if the word on the street
was to be believed and what other word
could I rely on Whitey Bulger could kill
you and your dog [ __ ] your wife burned
down your house and walk away clean the
South Boston I knew so well from the mid
70s through 1990 dripped with Irish
pride love for neighbour resistance to
outsiders in a desire to run its own
show it was a perfect place for a guy
like Whitey Bulger to build a massive
criminal enterprise and earn a
reputation as a gentleman bandit and
legendary Street walk warrior it was
also the perfect place for a politician
like Whitey's brother Billy Bulger to
build power I believe that Bulger Billy
Bulger was and remains one of South East
best assets I also believe that he
orchestrated corruption and helped run
interference for his brother against law
enforcement Billy had to have known what
his brother was up to whitey was up to
working for whitey gave me a feeling of
ultimate power with my background as a
fighter selling drugs for whitey made it
inevitable that I would do other things
for him as well
whitey ruled through intimidation and
fear anyone who assisted him in creating
a climate of intimidation in fear became
as the Boston Globe once wrote of me a
Bulger favorite my job description was
simple from 1985 to 1990 I worked for
whitey as a street soldier and enforcer
a leg-breaker
a drug runner I was hired muscle who
distributed drugs for my boss and broke
the limbs of who did those who
disrespected him I was often sent on
missions which made me feel like I was
pushing up the up against the icy
shoulder of death one night me and my
two buddies kidnapped him from his
apartment this was a drug dealer that
owed money and he was just not paying we
duct-taped his arms and legs throw him
in the trunk of a black Ford LTD
and headed out to Blue Hills in Milton
where we put two bullets in the back of
his head and bury him it was the first
time I'd had to kill anybody
be honest with you folks I wouldn't
killed him I would have let somebody in
the [ __ ] kill him but what's the
difference if you're with him and yeah
you're an accessory you're a murder so I
thank God that this particular story
came out that I didn't kill anybody it
was the first time I had to kill anybody
but I wasn't thinking much about what
that meant it was business nothing
personal we only had a couple of turns
to make before we were on 95 South 93
south when we saw the blue lights of a
cop cop flashing flashing turned out our
Chi had a broken taillight the two cops
looked into the con recognized its
occupants one asked us if we minded if
we looked in the trunk we said yeah of
course we do the trunk in and so we told
me get a search warrant so while the
police officer was getting a search
warrant the gentleman in the trucks name
was Bush we were yelling back to Bush
saying Bush listen we're playing war
games this is a God's honest truth
ascend the police report somewhere but
we're playing war games I'm going to
give you $10,000 to get out of South
Boston with your family and if you don't
tell the police that we're playing war
games and this was nothing other than
that we're gonna you know torture
basically tortured brutalized every
member of your family for every day
we're in jail for this if you don't play
ball with us so by the time the cops got
the search warrant to open the trunk
Bush was in there duct tape music mmm
they took the tape more games of just
the prisoner
I was really goofing off officer of
course the police didn't believe us they
arrested us and we got taken in you know
all over the place we were charged with
kidnapping and all this stuff but Bush
left South Boston and never came back so
you know no witness no no case so that
case was officially dismissed
so much has been written about Whitey's
intelligence and psychology
he continues to intrigue and perplex
people then again whitey was a gangsta
and America has long been fascinated by
organized crime and figures like Al
Capone Dutch Schultz Meyer Lansky Lucky
Luciano and John Gotti Whitey Bulger
will like was like all those guys and
like none of them he intimidated
controlled killed and made lots of money
from the rackets but he had his own way
of doing things and a cunning pathology
that separated him from the rest as
proof I submit that while most of
America's major organized mob bosses
have died either by violence or imprison
and shooting including John Gotti whitey
is still out there somewhere it wasn't
difficult to see how white he became a
leader of street thugs like myself in
the mean streets of Southie you not only
had to be smart and disciplined you also
had to be ruthless willing to kill when
necessary Whitey Bulger was the total
package and every one of us loved him
for it we wanted to be like him and be
near him because we saw the way he way
he was treated people not only respected
him they feared him we saw the way he
manipulated people and created an
organization that served him perfectly
we saw his money his girls his
connections his power we saw the way
that he did his time in prison in
Alcatraz and got out we saw the way that
he beat authorities year after year
running his rackets and staying out of
handcuffs we knew he wasn't fearless
that he didn't have the physical courage
to go one on one like many of us but
that was ok he had us to take care of
that part of the business he was still a
ferocious bastard and he could send the
fear of the devil through all of Sultan
now I'd like to end this because a lot
of people ask me when I'm reading where
you are today yet what do you do today
well I have five beautiful young
daughters I have three mothers and I'm
still single bang but I have 100%
custody of my 10 and 11 year old girls
and for me that's what my life is all
about right now
so end
with a little thing I wrote about them
with the little girls it's a lot easier
for now I try to read to Devyn who's ten
and Kayla who's nine every night last
night's story was Beauty and the Beast
about a young girl who gets lost trying
to find her father she comes upon a
castle with a huge ugly beast within
once Belle gets past the ugliness of the
Beast
she falls in love with the kind and
gentle person inside I told them you
can't judge people on their looks and
they listened every night after my story
my two dark-haired little beauties fall
off into sleep as I sit there watching
them certain no one will hit them
tomorrow and it will have enough to eat
and no one will poke fun at their
clothes because they don't fit they are
so peaceful lying near knowing their
daddy is close by to protect them and
hold them and tell them how much he
loves them I never forget that I have no
choice but to make Devon and Kayla my
whole life
every morning I give each girl a
smoochie kiss on the cheek to wake her
once they're up I make them breakfast
Devon likes her eggs over-easy
Kayla likes them scrambled no one ever
made me an egg when I was their age
which makes it all the sweeter for me to
do it for them once my girls bellies are
full and each school pack is full of
snacky and juice boxes were off as I let
them out of the car at their school I
take another moment to marvel at their
innocence i watch my precious little
chicks their every move each little step
I know without a question that I would
gladly give my life for my daughters
being a father is a gift from God that
gives me the chance to make up for what
happened to me as a child I've made a
lot of mistakes but this much I know for
sure my babies will always have a loving
father I will never let them down their
lives have to be better than mine as for
my future I hope that when Devin and
Kayla were grown they can understand the
truth about their daddy that he was a
bad man but he wasn't the worst man and
he even managed to improve himself and
do some good the best part of this
morning is my little Kayla just as she
opens the door to enter school for one
last second she turns back to look at
her daddy and blows me a kiss
I melt as I blow her when in return
thank you
sounds a little mushy for a mob leg
breaker but I tell you folks that's
where it's at people often often ask me
are you redeemed do you have any
redemption Eddie I said absolutely not I
don't have any remorse you don't
understand that's the jungle that's
where I grew up in the jungle if the
lion just eats a meal and the Lions
belly is full does that lion stop being
a predator
I doubt it I think not you know through
age you acquire the wisdom and knowledge
to truly know the difference between
right and wrong and the any-any
rejection through the eyes of Eddie Mack
comes to my innocent daughters my
children that I know that I can't
there's no way that I can trip I can't
mess up I got to be here for them I got
to make sure that they never experience
they never see what I saw so before they
open for questions I just want to show
you folks in the email that I got from
somebody and you know dealing with Ross
Moscato and Phyllis you know Ross was a
fantastic athlete got a full scholarship
running at BC so he's you know he seals
to them
he goes to the swimming and the
profanity and stuff like that but to me
Ross and Phyllis grew up in what I call
the leafy suburbs and you know they're
not naive by any means but they don't
you know rest necessarily had the psyche
and the lingo of what I call the street
predator so you know about a year and a
half ago we were bumping heads with the
Boston Globe and stuff like that so one
of my famous things was and you'll read
this throughout street soldiers all I
had to do with my reputation was come up
T and say listen Jimmy we got to
straighten his problem on ya you know I
don't want this to get ugly
this is gonna get ugly and it's all I
had to do was say then people just knew
right away oh I got to do this so here's
something from my bu professor that she
sent me on an email and this is Fox
Butterfield quoted me in the New York
Times a week ago I said that Boston is
best known for two things Paul
the tics and revenge I said here you
have politics William Bulger president
of the Massachusetts Senate and here you
have his brother whitey bulger revenge
that's what the Irish are best known for
uh and here's my email can't tell you
how thrilled thrilled I am with this Fox
is a real in-depth serious crime report
reporter for The Times and the fact that
he interviewed you is the best thing
that could possibly happen to your
credibility [ __ ] the globe you're in
there buddy
PS delete this email if you know what's
good for you I don't want this to get
ugly I'm gonna frame this house that was
great I didn't delete it feeling sorry
okay now if anybody wants to ask me any
questions feel free yes
that was a great story that you my two
questions did you serve any time and
what was the one thing that made you
decide that you were going to go
straight if that's the right word um yes
I served time in the I've served time
off and on through my life but in this
particular instance fifty-one of us went
to Danbury federal penitentiary no 51 of
us gone indicted ten of us went to
Danbury federal penitentiary in
connection with Whitey Bulger we stayed
in the hole for a couple days because
they couldn't process us till Monday so
one of the first people we see is
Raymond Patriarca jr. the Godfather of
all New England and he looks at as he
goes you guys know why you're here don't
you I guess yeah course we do ray we got
caught he goes no you didn't you got
served up by your boss Whitey Bulger
he's a rat he's a canary we've known
this for years a couple of the guys with
me got sick and on I just simply was in
denial a few years later it can't it
turned out that he was the biggest rat
of the mall Whitey Bulger um but at that
particular time I made a decision I says
I could get out of here now this is
crazy always I've been putting all these
years looking at this guy like he was
Cesar to me and you know people ask me
Eddie how'd you feel at that moment when
you found out that he was an informant I
feels well how do you think Caesar felt
when he got shanked by Brutus very
painful and deadly
so what I did was uh I negotiated a deal
with my Colombian connection I was able
to get you know the FBI of 40 to 50
million dollar cocaine deal basically
bought it for my freedom but that was
like the beginning of a turning point
you know getting pinched i I think folks
through all my life I've had this dr.
Jekyll and mr. Hyde thing with me
because I ran a local gym in South
Boston I taught much lots of many kids I
didn't charge ninety percent of them
they couldn't afford it I uh you know I
often took them to Chinatown for dinner
and those English subletter movies and
have did their homework with them and
stuff like that and by neck by night I
was mr. Hyde you know I was playing the
life of the underworld and so forth but
I think that the good seat in the bad
seed is has been a struggle in my life
but it's not overcome but the turning
point for me was being a Danbury federal
prisoner and I'd be fake to say that if
I didn't get pinched that day I might be
doing what I'm doing now I probably dead
or being Walpole or something like that
so now further that question by saying
all my life I believed in one thing you
know what I mean I'm you know I'm a
Roman Catholic but you know I got
problems with church and all that stuff
but I do believe in God
and I'd saw a movie that the colonel in
street soldier the guy that took care of
me for five and six years and the only
guy that really paid attention me that I
called dad he made me watch this movie
with him one time and it was called
somebody up there likes me and it was
Paul Newman it was about rocky Graziano
prizefight as I reference myself to that
and I go through life by saying you know
somebody up there likes you Eddie
somebody up there has you out here so if
I walk by a homeless man I'll pull a
buck out even if I only have a buck
fifty I'll throw it in there I'm saying
I can go without a coffee today you know
I mean stuff I do simple little things
like that I come across kids if I see
him acting goofy and stupid I say come
here what the way you guys doing you
know and I try to talk to him and try to
help everybody I come in contact because
I really believe what goes around comes
around I we could go into this forever
but we only got an hour so I'm sorry did
I answer that though we you okay yes
anybody else
yes No
with your brothers you know myself I
always thought that Asians are mostly
motivated by power and is it power that
the two of them are motivated by say in
the case of whitey it can't really be
money because he didn't really spend the
money but he it was all about getting it
somehow is it power what motivates them
well its power you know to me whitey
Bulger's week in insecure coward
anybody that has to shoot people
or maybe stab somebody in the back or
something like that or get guys like me
to do their dirty work
is a coward you know I've never like got
anybody from behind now I was third time
national heavyweight kickboxing champion
I won the Golden Gloves it was face to
face with me man you know a couple of
things I had to do a little
reconnaissance type stuff but I was a
hands-on type of guy I was a guy with
the balls I was the guy that wasn't the
coward guys like Whitey Bulger are
cowards they're all they're all
power-hungry what they do is they get at
the top there and then they have all
these people do their work and try to
make them look like the tough guys they
are then you go over to William Bulger
you know everybody takes William Bulger
for granted but I can honestly say that
William Bulger has done a lot for South
Boston William Bulger has done a lot for
the state of Massachusetts William
Belcher has done a tremendous amount for
the University of Massachusetts
it's William brother Bulger his
brother's keeper that's a tough question
did William Bulger protect his brother
and help his brother absolutely would I
protect my brother and help my brother
of course I would I was on NECN and Chet
Curtis asked me Eddie where do you draw
the line here you know the guy's a
serial killer Whitey's choked women he
murdered women I said Chet you don't
understand you know you're from the
leafy suburbs I'm from a tight-knit
Irish neighborhood of South Boston where
you know you have the Bulger brothers
you have John Connolly all grew up in
the Mary Ellen McCormack projects the
first projects in America I might add
and you know not only do you form a
loyalty for the kids that you grow up
with in that tight little neighborhood
you got five six seven Bulger brothers
living in a two or three-bedroom flat so
you got bunk beds everywhere if you form
an even more fierce a loyalty to your
brother now if I grew up in the leafy
suburbs where
Kozinski grew up he got served up by his
brother like that you know we wouldn't
serve up anybody from our neighborhood
no matter how sick they were you know
they say Whitey Bulger was a sociopathic
serial killing gangster but he was our
gangster that's how we saw it yes who
you felt might have been close to Whitey
Bulger uh you know something I can't
answer that because um you know I might
get a speeding ticket or something like
that I might have to pull a permit in
City Hall or something so I don't know
of anybody good question but if you know
if you know about Boston politics and
the Irish I'll give you a perfect
example mayor Curley one of the famous
mayors of South Boston is quoted as
saying of the Irish we're gonna out [ __ ]
you now we're gonna out vote you later
so the Irish do stick together
I'll get him and then I'll get you I'm
sorry good sir do you I'm from your same
kid you struck a code I'm from your same
genetic background I grew up in a
blue-collar I a little call of my
genetic background blue-collar town with
more Italians and poles and Irish so we
had a nice mix what made the fights even
and guys I'm older than you so the guys
I went to school with the Marine Corps
you're straightened them out or they're
in jail or some of them are dead you
know um but I'm wondering basically now
you're in your 40s right what yeah
everybody looks mad okay so money so so
so what is so how do you go back to the
neighborhood you can you go back to the
pub and have a beer and can you hang out
where you used to hang out well do your
dear can you go back into Southie and
walk the streets anyway you know I have
two daughters in Southie um you know I
work out at the local Athletic Club I've
been there five 15 16 years I play
racquetball I love to play racquetball
so I'm actually in Southie to this day
three have four days a week go back to
the local pub where ice to drink and
hang out I never did I owned up I owned
a pub in South Boston it's the only one
I hung out with because I was making
money I was never a real drinker I never
was into the nightclub scene Oh
time I was into nightclubs because I
worked in them and owned a couple in my
day you know but I'm in Southie a lot
and I see those people those same people
in the corner and stuff like that and I
make it a real point not to see them
because I want to put that behind me I
don't want to be like those people like
Jimmy Joey and Johnny that are on the
corner of D Street and Broadway and you
know they were brought up on a street
you know what I'm saying Southie is my
hometown well to me Southie is where I
come from but I don't want to die in
Southie I want to see the world I want
to take my daughter's and experience
life with them I don't want to hang out
with the boys and you know drink a
Guinness in the pub and stuff like that
least not them people I want to hang out
with with people like you you know what
I mean yes it seems like you've turned
your life around quite a bit though
Jesus yes well you looked pretty chest
was puffed up there when you said that
you were a tough guy there at the end
and do you still find yourself think
that sometimes things don't go your way
that you'd like to muscle somebody again
well I like to say I used to be live but
now I'm Memorex
but to be to be perfectly honest with
you what I call being a street predator
is like going to a a it's a battle I
have to fight every day for the rest of
my life you know I see sometimes I might
see a quick score and easy way out and
the only thing that deters me and it's a
sad to have to say this but it's real
important to say this too is my children
you know if I didn't have kids I'd
probably still be in the game you know
because it's I became a product of in my
environment folks it's the way it's all
I really know you know what I mean the
jungle it's all it's all I know I mean
um huh children know what type of life
you had before
well my 17 and 18 year old have both
read the book they live in South Boston
they've been in private school from day
one because because of busing probably
Boston Public Schools no good but the
ten and eleven year old they're gonna
have to get a little bit older and
mature enough to understand what this is
all about anyway so they don't need to
know that right now I will say that
thanks to Hollywood the movies that come
all today nothing really surprises kids
you know they they read this my daughter
Cody's like hey Dad I read a few tales
pretty cool I thought I saw something
similar
that a movie last week you know and then
it you know another important thing to
me is people ask me how you shield your
daughters how are you going to protect
your daughters you know against men and
all these things like that I go slow
you know when we wanted to get laid in
South Boston we would go to your
neighborhood in the leafy suburbs
because that's where you shielded your
kids and they were young naive and they
were basically easy prey you try to get
laid in South Boston you're buying a
30-pack you're going on movie you're
gonna get dinner it's gonna take you a
little bit because nobody's jumping your
bones from my neighborhood without
working for it
you understand I'm saying okay did I
answer that was it okay you got more
okay okay jack and then I'll get to you
sir it would you comment on your
relationship with John Connolly and what
do you think is going to happen to him
in the future um my relationship with
John calling up in his house many times
the vet coffee with coffee with the man
all along I thought that Whitey Bulger
had owned the FBI he had a few not the
FBI as a whole you know I want to make
it loud and clear folks I'm not knocking
the FBI you know I just believe in every
bushel of apples is a few bad apples in
the Boston office has got this huge
stain and they get a few bad apples
there but they all set themselves up for
the fall because they took John Connolly
from the FBI sent them back into the
neighborhood where he grew up with
Whitey Bulger he old Billy Bulger
because Billy Bulger basically got him
in college and helped him in so many
things from so he just went back to
where he came from and Mick straight in
my feelings about John Connolly is you
know he's about 61 62 whatever he's
looking at the next nine or ten years in
prison us you know believe he's going to
do that because he has a lovely young
wife he has some really handsome young
twins some kids and boys million and a
half dollars with the property out there
and so much to lose if he doesn't get up
and follow suit like the rest of them
and start singing the soprano so I
honestly believe that um you'll be
seeing John Connolly very soon singing
yes if you ran into like a young version
of you someone in their late 20s maybe
early 30s who had been getting involved
in organized crime and they asked you
for some advice to be staying it to get
out of it what would you tell them well
you know I'd say don't whatever you do
don't watch The Sopranos
and you know don't watch Goodfellas and
stuff like that because my opinion of
those shows is it sounds a little
topsy-turvy they're great entertainment
but that's what they are folks they're
entertainment some of its real but most
of its glorified in this life is
short-lived and what they don't show
yeah they show some gory scenes people
getting sawed up too in the back of the
head the traditional you know legendary
storytelling at the Mafia and stuff like
that throw out there but you know you
see here I'll give you what I'm saying
is Tony Soprano's up he's got his lovely
wife his children going to the best
colleges around in a beautiful home but
when Tony Soprano gets indicted and
thrown away there's three more people
that are going on welfare that we're
going to be paying for their whole lives
are going to be ruined you don't think
about victims like that and then you
don't think about the many families of
the people that they murder and that
they extort from I mean come on you have
people that come over to this country as
immigrants to Ellis Island through New
York oh well you know however way they
find it where this is American leader to
me America is the promised land land of
opportunity where you can call Bush a
war monger an [ __ ] you don't get
dragged out of your house at midnight
right so you know what I mean
and um these hard-working people are
just trying to make their niche in life
and then they have their own people who
are the bad apples who thrive off them
and suck the blood out of them like the
whitey Bulger's with the Irish the
Gottis with the Italians the Russians
they're preying on their own people you
know what I'm saying
to me that's it's very very wrong but
you don't see that side yes I want to
follow up on the addicted person or
addictive personality a thing as far as
the street predator is concerned yeah
you know reference it concerns me a
little because we all have we all have
different kinds of support systems to
help us when we have some issues if if
we were addicted to a drug or to alcohol
whatever we have organizations we have
support systems we have counseling to
help us a little through that and I
heard you remark about your daughter's
being your support system in a sense
I'll put you on the spot by saying I
don't think that's enough do you think
that's enough to help you through what
you called yourself an addictive
personality you got a high you know use
that expression you got a high from the
violence that you're involved with how
do you help yourself not to continue
that need for that high I watch The
Sopranos I watch it on TV and I and I
live it through TV you know what I mean
I'm like oh cool that really enough of a
support system for me there's five
support systems it's it's Britni Devin
Kayla Courtney and Lauren I can't say it
any better folks five beautiful girls
that need me they need my support they
need me to be strong I have to set the
example for them if I continue along the
way I am today and if I fall off the
ladder where they gonna be you know I
don't want to be in Walpole Prison
thinking about those five innocent
little children that are out there going
about to embark on a life without a
father without you know Kourtney's gone
hopefully she's going to Boston
University next year Laurens finishing
her senior year in a wonderful private
school for girls nobody's gonna pay that
if I'm gone you don't I mean I'm the
support I'm not I'm the machine that
keeps these girls happy that keeps them
going I can't fall I can't slip you know
I mean now if I didn't if I didn't have
my girls then you got me I don't know
what I do but I'm blessed I mean you're
fiercely competitive still in your
excess laughs yeah racquetball and stuff
like that I'm fiercely competitive
because I mean athlete I was a
professional fighter you know I walked
into the University of Massachusetts I
was 34 years old and the coach was coach
Kent I never played football I just cuz
I never went to high school I dropped
out of the 10th grade and went into the
Marine Corps and then I um so I walked
on in the University of Massachusetts
and I said coach Kent was a probation
officer I go scotch I want to play
football he's all right get a physical
and my buddy ran the South Boston Health
Center I won't say what year and I won't
say his name but he made me look like I
was 26 27 years old it gave me a great
rapport you know so here I am playing
football with these with these kids and
I still don't know the terminology so
fire coach what position in my
plan and he knew a bum you know and he
goes put it this way Mac if I tell you
to kill the quarterback I don't really
mean it you know I so I was a defensive
tackle and I actually got killed over
there but I you know I played every game
and had a blast but to me athleticism
and uh you know through physical
strength and physical stability you keep
the body healthy the mind stays healthy
you know I'm saying if I was drinking
and boozing and and basically not taking
care of myself
then my chances are really grabbing a
score or falling off the ladder would be
more because my mind would be weak but
I'm a very mentally tough person I can
deal with just about anything that comes
my way you know when you get sodomized
at the age of nine and you get raped at
17 going into the I went into the army
first and I got raped right before I
went in and and you know when those
things happen to you and then you follow
up by being and basically a scumbag for
whitey bulger for five or six years and
you get entrenched into that world you
know you form a resilience to be able to
say hey wait a minute
this is - this is yesterday but today is
today I gotta take a nice deep breath of
fresh air and I got a look for today I
can't think about yesterday anymore so
you know these terrible things that
happen to me in my life I'm able to just
click it off like that you folks
wouldn't even known about it had I not
written this book street soldier with
these two folks because I remember
sending the first scene about being nine
years old being taken by the tutor and
you know sodomized raped and all this
madness happened to me and then both the
emails Phyllis being Jewish was like Oy
Vey my god Roz was like what the [ __ ]
yeah
so he was it pretty hard pretty horrible
stuff you know but once again you you
know you can't live for yesterday you
gotta live for today folks yes I'll get
you right out I'm sorry could you speak
a little bit about your experiences as a
foster child well I'll tell you you know
I was dropped off at the front steps
I'll never forget this and it's amazing
at the young age of like four or five
years old what someone can remember I
remember my mother and father saying
they were gonna give me a dime so I
could get a candy bar
my whole life I've never forgotten that
one sentence because it's the last I've
ever seen them I guess they're you know
in the span of the next year the first
foster home that we went to they
combined they dropped off toys and stuff
like that which were soon as day left
the toys were immediately packaged and
given to the real real sons and
daughters of the foster people that were
there you know the first two foster
homes you know we basically slapped
around kicked around we couldn't sit on
the couch we had to sit on the floor we
were treated like animals you know and
they winter in it for the money
one foster home I am was broken for
about three weeks the people just didn't
want believe me and finally the person
the lady at school for my crying and
complaining and not being able to go
like this took me in a time dang that's
that's the only time he took me out of
their foster home I lucked out when I
went to Jamaica Plain and I got the
colonel who I called dead but once again
I was in that foster home
before he came along I had gotten raped
so you know the seed was planted the
predatory seed was planted and folks in
the world I come from you know the inner
city the suburb the the inner sanctum of
the projects living and all that kind of
stuff that's the jungle and everybody
starts him in the jungle as prey your
young innocent and your prey and Eddie
Mack was young and innocent prayed he
was not alone there are many edimax out
there and you know that age of nine the
prey the innocence started to get taken
away and as soon as I get a little old
and got tough enough that was it
I said I'm going to be the predator now
now it's my turn to give back and I
tried it through being a professional
fighter I figure I can beat the tar out
of people and not going to get arrested
but it was still I didn't have the
guidance that I was looking for and you
know street soldiers not a know what was
me story by any means because I've had
opportunities along the way people have
tried to help me but I was too young
ignorant and already turning into the
predator that I became did I answer them
okay you had mentioned that on that I
jogged calmly you thought had with would
did we'd be seeing him soon because he
had information offer why do you think
that he hasn't done so so far
I don't think John Conlee expected the
sentence that he was going to get I
honestly believe Big Brother was looking
out for Big Brother I'll give you a
perfect example of why I think Big
Brother's looking off was looking out
you know it's an awful thing I've never
asked for any of my kids I never planned
and planned them but I stepped up to the
plate for every single one of them and
when I first had Devin I only her mother
was a one-night stand as awful as it
sound you know sounds the male anatomy
has two brains attached to it my brain
was thinking that night so Bango I got a
kid you know Cathy comes walking by
seven months later pregnant I'll try to
speed it up so I'll make the story too
long and I look at her and I'm like hey
Cathy you gonna have a kid honey she
goes no we're gonna have a kid I was
like yeah that was in denial and I
hadn't see her for seven months so I'm
in front of the judge to make a long
story short and he wants me if the DNA
test comes back 98.9% you're the fun he
wants me the signed acknowledgment
apparently I'm still in utter denial I'm
like are you kidding me schlep everybody
in town you know I'm trying to say
everything bad it was wasn't nice but
that's what I said i-gos Your Honor I
can't do that and I almost got thrown in
jail for this it's very comical says
Your Honor I can't do then goes why
can't you do that mr. Mackenzie because
well I think there's a conspiracy going
on here sir I honestly believe that that
not CES says she wolf that you had
stabbed me in the arm in there take the
DNA test and the court mediator and the
court-appointed attorney that you gave
me and you know no disrespect for you
your honor
your work for the same people you all
get the same paycheck every week so
what's to say that you know just because
my name is the only name in the Hat then
I gotta get hooked for the next 18 years
he's like yeah you're the parent you're
paying on a bucks that we got Mike what
else I was like we should listen but
same thing with John Carney good old boy
network looking out for each other here
you have a guy that has a million and a
half dollars worth of property $80,000
speedboat he's on an FBI pension you
don't see anybody moving to take his
pension away like the you know the
Herald had reported a year ago they're
taking all these corrupt officials
pensions maybe is even a mention of it
he probably figured I were gonna toss
you for a couple years make everybody
think well you know we're doing any
thought he's gonna now we realized that
it was no nonsense this time he got 10
12 years or whatever he got so now he's
like Oh reality's setting in I didn't
get what I was looking for that's why
you think he's
to return do you think he has a lot to
offer oh absolutely absolutely that man
set up a lot of people to be killed you
know you don't parade through the
Statehouse with young FBI agents to meet
William Bulger all the time and then
from there go over to cell bus and grab
a couple cases of liquor from the cell
boss Liquor Mart for your local FBI
potty and you don't walk into the
Broadway appliance store owned by Kevin
or Kevin O'Neill and Whitey Bulger and
pick on appliances for FBI agents and I
personally carried a refrigerator with
Joanne Presti and John Connolly cells
from the appliance store all gifts you
know what I mean and so he's got a lot
to say this book is a major point in
your life and so have you try to project
out at all five years ten years you know
we get to do our drivers lights and
silver in the state every five years and
you have to look at that picture and say
what the hell did I do over the last
five years and have you thought ahead
what it was like on ahead yeah I know
five years oh well yeah I'm working on
another book management secrets for the
mob how the Dawn's wield power and
succeed and you know maybe I'll write a
book after that maybe I don't I really
don't know but my hope and dreams is you
know the most powerful message that I
have in this book is just because you
don't like the messenger don't discount
the message it's a very powerful message
here folks and I'm looking forward to
going to high schools you know something
I've done all my life with my gym
helping kids anyways I'm looking forward
to going to high schools I'm looking
forward to going to colleges and talking
to the kids and just trying to let them
know that hey let me tell you something
I don't have any excuses if I can do it
you can do it now I'll give you a
perfect example I did a speech at Stony
Hill College last year two to three
hundred kids there was fantastic I got
my Scooby Doo baseball cap on and my
shirt out and I'm in the audience trying
not to get detective it's about a week
or so after 60 minutes and all the kids
are coming any dumb undergrad you know
they don't know anything you know as far
as what's going on around them they only
know what time the frat parties going on
and stuff like that so I'm like and
they're talking like oh this Eddie
McKenzie bobbing for that leg back up
more man
you know and they still don't know
that's me sitting with nobody's paying
attention so gentleman comes in and he
introduces me and then I get up and all
of a sudden it's like you couldn't hear
a pin drop it was like a deer in
headlights kids awake and so now I come
down it's a golden opportunity I goes
here's my first lesson of the day kids
respect you never know who's next to you
in life you got to respect everybody and
then of course I got to be classic Eddie
Mac and horrify the professors and I
grabbed the mic I goes because I'll
[ __ ] kill everyone is and they were
like wow this guy's cool man yeah you
know and then you should have saw the
emails after that you know they were
sending emails like this guy was
unbelievable it's great you know so
that's I like to send that message to
people if I get that opportunity no
follow-up ah yes hold on a second when
you get out of the prison yeah when you
get out of prison what did you use for
skills to sustain yourself to survive on
like day to day when you got released
from prison what did I use yeah just to
say aliens you know I've been on my own
when I was about 12 or 13 years I used
to sleep under porches my idea was
shopping was going on clotheslines in
those days they had all the clothes
hanging on clotheslines
so I basically picked my outfits as I
shot the round you know and I and I got
the best and then you know graduating
from thief and all that stuff and
learning how to you know in the interim
I did work you know I used to try to do
the right thing and paint and carpentry
and then I you know I was a DJ and stuff
like that and on you know most of my
life I've been a leader I've been a
go-to type of guy you know and then I
often I would get what I call givers
remorse sometimes but then I'd get over
that real quick because I basically give
you the shirt off my back I'd do
anything for you that I could help you
and stuff like that and sometimes people
would say what the hell'd you do that
for he'd never do that for you I'd be
like yeah I know but it made me feel
good to do it you don't understand you
know I'm saying so you know those skills
and all of all the life experiences and
the friends that I made a long
the way you know DJ and paid my way
through college and it was getting 350
to about 1200 for weddings and parties
and still was great cash you know if
they to the writers there how did you
make that connection to bring your
history into their realm so that they
could actually develop it into a book so
that we could all appreciate and learn
from well there here's another way on
how I sustain myself gentleman owned a
nationwide trade show company he was
working in Boston he had a bunch of
great kids from you know Easton and the
you know the suburb the leafy suburb
area all good hard-working kids that
wanted to make money when they come in
to sell bus and then they got it take
what we call the Union mentality you
know every two hours I want my break but
I'm only going to work five minutes and
55 minutes I'm going to be over the pub
having a few shots with the fellas and
basically stretching the job out as long
as I can but the you know these kids
from the suburbs didn't know that all
they knew was you know a day's pay a
day's work so the guy that was trying to
break into the trade show business would
having a lot of trouble with the like
Hells Angels and South Boston thugs and
stuff like that because they would say
people from South Boston and stuff and
I'm not knocking people from South
Boston but this is just the way they
were they were saying hey what are you
doing you working too hot you know take
a little longer and stuff like then so
they created a little animosity between
the guy and his crew and they was
slashing his tires smashing his truck
windows and basically trying to drive
him out so buddy of mine introduced me
to the owner and to make a long story
short he turned out to be very very good
friends now you know I still basically
worked for the company occasionally and
I was able to make all his problems go
away within one day you know and so we
and he gave me a retainer for and it was
a nice way to make some money and then
along the way of helping him and working
with him he says man you got a book in
you he goes I got Ross Muscato kid that
he grew up with you know this is from
East and you know they're all athletes
and they all went to Oliver Ames High
School and they got a big family
tradition
tight neighborhood he goes he's a
strategic writer you know and you know
once he introduced me to Ross so what
happened was me and Ross you know I I'm
writing like Ross said I wrote most of
it and I kind of had a talent for
bringing you into my world and telling
you my story so I'd send it all
with this book was mostly done on
Internet by the way because I'd be up at
three and one and seven over these ten
page emails and horrifying the both of
them
so me and Ross did the manuscript and
we're a couple of amateurs so we're
trying to peddle it in New York and
trying to get it done and we can't get
it done so another friend of mine Joel
Kurtzman who's in charge of world
thought management for
PricewaterhouseCoopers you know and he's
written some books before he introduced
us to Helen Reese an agent in Boston and
we went to Helen Reese and she said well
the first thing you got to do is you got
to get an author that's known and
accomplished author to sell the book and
to help you put the feminine touch to it
and make it better because do you know
two Irish guys and stuff like that it
was pretty Ron manly so then he
introduced us must confess I never heard
fellatio described as kamikaze dive on a
joystick till I met you
okay yeah I don't even know what
fellatio means if you want to swifty but
no just I learnt it at a later day but
kamikaze on a joystick I know that
Austin bridge did I do what you ever
caught a bluefish off the South Boston
bridge yeah yeah stripers I've thrown a
few people have them so anyways here we
meet Phyllis Karras I meet her for the
first time and once again I'm not into
myself or anything like that but I don't
know who may I don't think it was
Phyllis cuz her husband's here and he's
great guy ah I get trouble I think Helen
said you got great I said you know blue
eyes and so I said Helen
don't let the blue eyes fool you because
what I'm about to tell you would make
any Quentin Tarantino movie look like
Bambi and then they started to read then
Phyllis was like then we got Phyllis and
then you know because of her name and so
forth we were able to sell the book and
that's how it all started
yes
to followup on that could we ask Phyllis
what it was like as a woman from the
leafy suburbs and during your world
could she speak to my dear Phyllis I
never really got that the scuttlebutt on
that my son from the leafy suburbs
working with these two was certainly was
interesting but you know it is actually
a lot of women in this book is for four
wives is five daughters is mothers of
children who did not become wives is a
lot of different women so I think that
the feminine touch you know can be used
in this book and I think it had its
certain purpose certainly a lot of the
language was not language that I was as
used to as Ross and Eddie so II really
didn't tone it down I mean that's what
it was but I've been amazed at how many
women that have actually read the book
and have said that they're enjoying it
and that they find that this book is is
has a woman's audience as well as a
man's audience the things Eddie had to
explain to me for instance
cocaine truthfully I had never seen it I
had never used it I had never sold it
I had never cut it in from bricks into
little packages and I remember Eddie
trying to explain to me how that was
done
and he actually used an image of a
tomato paste can and explained you know
if you take it tomato paste key in and
then you put it in it was all these
instruments that they used to break it
down so I thought that was it was sort
of interesting to see a leg-breaker
describing things about cocaine with the
tomato paste can but there were lots of
these instead like the cook yeah yeah
look stir cook and I'm sure you know I
drove him crazy you know there was a lot
of explanations that I had to have clear
and that I didn't grasp that the two of
them grasped right away but maybe it was
better you know the explanations because
maybe it made the book a little better
for women to read as well because it is
I really believe a woman's book as well
is a man's book if you just get over the
language it's there to any help that's
the woman's take on Westville I have
evidence right here two folks
she's definitely a changed person I had
the evidence right here yeah you don't
want this to get ugly
yes as a pair like I'm on Jerry Springer
who's this guy go as a parent I am a
willing hostage for life for my kids and
I think you understand that how in the
world are you gonna keep your daughters
safe after this I mean aren't there guys
who are mad at you stay in shape for the
rest of my life um other guys that are
mad at me
yeah probably Whitey Bulger and Steve
Flemmi but you know I don't really
implicate people in street soldier I
just share stories with everybody in the
beginning I wanted to write some of the
names have been changed to protect them
not so innocent but you know they
wouldn't let me put that Eddie Mack
humor in there so they just said some of
the names have been changed but um you
know Whitey Bulger and Steve Flemmi were
free tomorrow found not guilty these
guys have been act top act alone
informants for two decades they've sold
a you know their friends everybody out
there's so many people want to kill them
they could never resurface they could
never come back to the neighborhood
where they were at so in that sense I'm
not worried about that but um am I
afraid of course I'm afraid I you know
but coming from where I come from you
learn to live with fear you learn to
embrace fear one of our presidents once
said we have nothing to fear but fear
itself you know I'm saying so you know I
wake up with fear every day I go to a
restaurant my backs to the wall I want
to I study the exits I study everybody
Ron I could have a huh I mean it must be
hard uh it's not high because I don't
think that way you know it's it's not
the way you think you know it's it's
really an unwritten code you don't go
after kids and stuff like that you could
never go to prison if you did that
because you get killed many parents in
prison that are from this world that I'm
from they hate rapists diddles that's
why they taught you these people when
they go to jail and stuff you you just
don't think about going after someone's
children you know they made a movie
Scarface and hey you have Tony Montana
well Montoya whatever his name was Al
Pacino one of the most vicious Cuban
mafia figures who kill anybody but he
couldn't blow that car up with the young
innocent kid in it
see what I'm saying so I try not to
worry about that
I will say that once you have kids I'm a
firm believer this you no longer have a
life of your own lucky for me I've been
there when I done that so you know if
dr. Kara's called me today and said
Eddie I got Devon in the hospital you
got to give you HOT to her she needs a
transplant see you later
I'm gone because I'll do anything for my
kids hope I get you some business out of
this anybody else
yes well you know I've often thought he
was sleeping in the Meadowlands with
Jimmy Hoffa or he he might be dressed in
drag laughing at rural America for
basically getting away with a life of
crime because not only was he whitey
bulger associate Pathak serial killing
machine
he was also ac/dc he swung both ways he
was a crossdresser he dressed up as a
old lady many times one time we're
standing on the corner for the five of
us and a lady comes by and she bumps us
and she watched for five feet oh and you
know one of us got wise he goes well
excuse me ma'am and the lady turned her
on it was a doing a [ __ ] excuse me I
could have killed every single one years
we were like I was waiting Bulger you
know like he's must have been practicing
or he must have been on his way to whack
somebody or somebody we are horrified it
was unbelievable
now what your life was like when you're
in the military where you're in a more
restricted society Terry it was
short-lived was it uh but but uh
released honorably thank God
yes five girls was a boy
how would you keep the boy clean how I
kick his ass now
I've never hit any one of my kids I give
them maybe a what I call a cracking a
little smack on the button but you know
the relationship that I have with my
kids is you know if you give them an
inch they take a mile
the geese my Devin and Kayla will talk
back to their mother you just couldn't
imagine you know my foster mother the
only lady I call mom had what I call the
boomerang show if I was in the living
woman she told me how to do something I
talked back to her that sure would go
down that hallway and hook her on and
nail me right between the eyes two or
three times of doing that I never talked
back to my mother my kids they test me
every now and then because they're kids
they've got to test to see how far they
can go
and once they flip talk I get them right
away and it goes hey don't talk back to
me like that young you know I get Stern
with them but I only have to do that a
couple times when it comes to the
extreme extreme like if you know I
called them Irish twins they're 10 and
11 now so they go at it like cats and
dogs and you know I give him a little
crack so both it's about that hot
they're so hurt that I gave him a crack
in their likes and of course I gotta get
out of here cuz I'm ready to stop
bawling myself and you took the time out
to I predict oh yeah
time outs and stuff like that half an
hour later we're gonna do equi because I
feel so guilty and I I think so man but
you know that's it'd be different
with some of your personality traits and
some of your guys you know my daughter
Courtney is 19 years old a couple of
days ago since just as big as I am she
won the state championships with boys
and girls team and won the state
championships for Latin Academy and
hockey as a goalie I've seen her slam
people on the ice like it was nothing
and you know she's as tough as they come
and then I've seen the whole team jumper
and love her and hug her and everybody
rally behind her so if I ever had a boy
it's you know I hope you're not watching
this Courtney because I love you and
you're a girl but you know she's as
tough as they come and she takes right
after her father so if I had a boy you
know a big escape for me in a big way of
overcoming racism for me was through
athleticism
it's nothing in the world you know you
see these racists and out the street
they're killing and going crazy but you
walk into a boxing gym or you go to a
championship fight and you
No you got this big black guy across
from you and y'all over here and you're
both gonna beat the tar out of each
other you want to really you don't want
to win this fight you're beating the
daylights out of each other for a 10
rounder and at the end you're hugging
and saying man it was great I was
awesome you know nobody thinking racism
when they do that so for me the way I
really overcome racism was was through
athleticism and stuff like that and you
know go walking into UMass and getting
that Malcolm X books that was a big
turning point for me you know so that's
how I do it with if I had a son I'd make
sure he was his mind was healthy his
body was strong and he was at a point to
where you know he didn't want it he
didn't want anything to tear himself
down I believe I'm guilt gifted folks
you know my brother Ronnie he went the
drug road you know he was on a cocaine
you got whacked out one day he did three
armed robberies that the poor kid he was
so whacked out on drugs and cocaine he
walked out of his house walked 50 feet
into store 24 pulled up magda money goes
give me a pack of marbles and everything
you got in a register they came it was
like something of the Keystone Cops he
walks a hundred yards up and he goes
into Brigham Z [ __ ] he's like he goes
into Brigham Eagles give me a [ __ ]
hot fudge sundae right now [ __ ] and all
the money in the register this all in
the police reports and as he was robbing
them the cops were flying a store 24 so
he's like got his hot fudge sundae as
mild borrows he's like and he goes maybe
another 150 yards to the liquor store
you give me a give me a pack give me a
six-pack of but lightning and the lady
there goes Ronnie what the hell are you
doing here shut up I'm thirsty and he
takes that and he goes around the corner
where he lived
Broadway's here store 24 Brigham's
liquor store around the corner he lives
maybe 200 yards he's sitting on the
front step hot fudge sundaes melted
everywhere you know he's got the button
he's the things in the cops pull up say
Ronnie way to get in and I say okay I
just finished the sundae you know so
bang here he is for three armed
robberies but that saved his life
the only guy you know if my lawyer is el
Nugent he's he's a great lawyer you know
and and we became friends over and he
wrote the fold in the book he actually
one of the few times in his career
tried to put somebody in jail we shopped
around with two or three judges to get
my brother
that day kapa Moe committed going get
him off the streets
but it saved his life folks because you
know he I got I got a beautiful niece
and nephew and he's got a lovely wife
and he just bought his first home which
I'm proud to say I helped him helped him
get and stuff like that and you know
he's had a great job his wife's got a
great job it's it's all over for him for
me I was so mentally tough and
physically tough through fighting
anything that took over my body in the
form of drugs or if I got pet if I got
to that fourth beer where I felt like
this I was like wow I can't I don't want
this you know I tried cocaine you know I
tried the speed and smoked some angel
dust one time but I for maybe a week and
then I was got paranoid I didn't want
anybody to tell anything to take over I
wanted to work on it wanted to be
healthy so that's what I do if I had a
son I trained him to think about his
mind and body and his mental toughness
and and he'd be so busy reading books
and stuff like that he wouldn't have
time to think about that you know point
about about you denying or trying to to
fight the addiction of drugs or alcohol
because she wanted clarity you wanted to
think clear is that am I saying it
correctly yeah I wanted mental strength
I wanted clarity I wanted to think think
clear but most importantly my father was
a drunken slob a loser you know he
stayed we found him like I was on the
ankle bracelet my brother Ronnie wanted
to find my father I never kid yeah I
never knew you never stepped up the
plate never did anything me I don't want
to know you but I anyways I fly him down
to Florida found my father my father
gets on a phone he's living in a little
shed he's a roofer he's a bum and he's
talking well maybe I'll get up in a few
weeks in the sea and listen and I goes
we'll listen you know I hope you're
making good money goes you got about a
million dollars saved I was 35 he goes
online you know I know it goes well
that's what it's gonna cost you you
prick for all the years that you put me
through I go get the [ __ ] off the phone
and send me a picture and my brother's
pleading with me Eddie come on it's my
dad it's hard addicts hey my father I
just sent me a picture cuz I was always
curious you want to know what your dad
looks like you know and that's and I
never want to be like that so that was a
that's a good driving force for me too
it's and some books okay we're gonna
sign some books um so that's it thank
you thank you very much
Street soldier is published by steer
fourth press on the web at steer fourth
calm